with these words he led his army against
mithra deities having 20 000 foot
soldiers and 2500 horsemen
[Music]
but when he had come within sight of the
enemy and seen with amazement to their
multitude he decided to refrain from
battle and draw out the time
but presently as they were on the point
of joining battle with no apparent
change of weather but all on a sudden
the sky burst asunder and a huge
flame-like body was seen to fall between
the two armies
in shape it was most like a wine jar and
in color like molten silver
both sides were astonished at the sight
and separated
this marvel as they say
occurred in phrygia
at a place called trije
this video was sponsored by magellan tv
question where was the oldest discovered
intentional human burial found was it a
shannada cave in iraq b pangaya saeedi
in kenya or c kaspar in galilee israel
that's right kaspar is the oldest yet
found at about 92 000 years old and so
my recommendation this week is one of
magellan's new documentaries which they
add every week the last rites ceremonies
of death is an incredible dive into
different cultures reactions to life
ending and how it can be a positive
force in some societies it's an
eye-opening journey and one that gave me
loads of ideas for future videos and of
course magellan have more than 3 000
other documentaries already on their
system to check out too and this
christmas voices of the past viewers can
take advantage of a special holiday
offer a buy one get one free gift card
for an annual membership by clicking on
the link in the description
in the month of april 14 1561 at
daybreak between 4 and 5 am a dreadful
apparition occurred on the sun
and this was seen in nuremberg in the
city before the gates and in the country
by many men and women
at first there appeared in the middle of
the sun two blood-red semi-circular arcs
just like the moon in the last quarter
above and below and on both sides of the
sun the colour was blood and in the sun
there stood a round ball of partly dull
partly black ferrous colour in between
these globes there were visible a few
blood-red crosses between which there
were blood-red strips becoming thicker
to the rear and in the front malleable
like the rods of reed grass
these all started to fight among
themselves the globes flew back and
forth among themselves and fought
vehemently with each other for over an
hour
and when the conflict in and out of the
sun was most intense they became
fatigued to such an extent that they all
as said above fell from the sun down
upon the earth as if they all burned
and they then wasted away on the earth
with immense smoke
after all this there was something like
a black spear very long and thick
sighted the shaft pointed to the east
the point
pointed west
whatever such signs mean
god alone knows although we have seen
surely one after another many kinds of
signs on the heaven which are sent to us
by the almighty god to bring us to
repentance we still are unfortunately so
ungrateful that we despise such high
signs and miracles of god
the god fearing will by no means discard
these signs but will take it to heart as
a warning of their merciful father in
heaven will mend their lives and
faithfully beg god that he may avert his
wrath including the well-deserved
punishment on us
so that we may temporarily hear and
perpetually there live as his children
[Music]
in this year one james everl a sober
discreet man and two others saw a great
light in the night
at muddy river
when it stood still it flamed up and was
about three yards square
when it ran it was contracted into the
figure of a swine
it ran as swift as an arrow towards
charlton and so up and down about two or
three hours
they came down in their lighter about a
mile and when it was all over the men
found themselves carried quite back
against the tide to the place they came
from
diverse other credible persons saw the
same light
after at about the same place
[Music]
on february the 22nd 1803
local fishermen of the harriadori shore
in hitachi province saw an ominous ship
drifting in the waters
curious they towed the vessel back to
land discovering that it was three
meters high and five meters wide
reminding the witnesses of a kohaku
its upper part appeared to be made of
red coated rosewood while the lower part
was covered with brazen plates obviously
to protect it against sharp edged rocks
the upper part had several windows made
of glass or crystal covered with bars
and clogged with some kind of tree resin
the windows were completely transparent
and the baffled fishermen looked inside
the inner side of the utsuru bune was
decorated with texts written in an
unknown language
the fisherman found items inside such as
two bed sheets a bottle filled with
three and a half liters of water some
cake and needed meat
then the fisherman saw a beautiful young
woman possibly 18 or 20 years old her
body size was said to be one and a half
meters
the woman had red hair and eyebrows the
hair elongated by artificial white
extensions the extensions could have
been made of white fur or thin white
powdered textile streaks
this hairstyle cannot be found in any
literature
the skin of the lady was a very pale
pink color she wore precious long and
smooth clothes of
unknown fabrics the woman began speaking
but no one understood her she did not
seem to understand the fisherman either
so no one could ask her about her origin
although the mysterious woman appeared
friendly and courteous she acted oddly
for she always clutched a quadratic box
made of pale material and around half a
metre in size
the woman did not allow anyone to touch
the box no matter how kindly or
pressingly the witnesses asked
an old man from the village said
this woman could be a princess of a
foreign realm who married at her
homeland but when she had an affair with
a townsman after marriage it caused a
scandal and the lover was killed for
punishment
the princess was banned from home for
she enjoyed lots of sympathy so she
escaped the death penalty instead she
might have been exposed in that
utsurobune to leave her to destiny
if this should be correct the quadratic
box may contain the head of the woman's
deceased lover
in the past a very similar object with a
woman was washed ashore on a close by
beach
during the incident a small board with a
pinned head was found
the contents of the box could therefore
be the same which would certainly
explain why she protects it so much
it would afford lots of money and time
to investigate the woman and her boat
since it seems to be tradition to expose
these boats at sea we should bring the
woman back to the utsuro bune and let
her
drift away
from human sight it might be cruel but
it seems to be her predetermined destiny
and so the fishermen reassembled the
atsurobune place the woman in it
and set it to drift away
into the ocean
[Music]
someone must be operating an airship in
this portion of the state
twice within the past six weeks it has
been seen by reliable residents of
oakland and on each occasion it has
presented the same appearance
six weeks ago a young lady was riding a
wheel on telegraph avenue when she saw a
strange-looking object in the sky
it appeared to descend gradually but
regularly as though under perfect
control and it disappeared in the
direction of san francisco
another witness to the visit of the
airship is selby yast a member of the
oakland guard he was a little behind
time and was taking his car towards
piedmont trying to recover the few
minutes he was behind as he passed 30th
street a little boy stood in the road
and cried gee whiz what's that
the passengers heard it and immediately
looked at the direction in the sky where
the boy was pointing they had no
difficulty in seeing the airship when i
looked ahead said mr yass today i was
mystified and i may as well confess i
was
i don't like to admit to myself that i
had suddenly gone crazy but really for a
moment i did wonder if my senses had
abandoned me
the most peculiar feature of it was a
powerful headlight and another light
which seemed to be in the bottom of the
machine and to shine directly on the
earth
it came into view from the direction of
east oakland passing over piedmont and
according to the story of the passengers
seemed to descend in such a manner as to
indicate that it would land somewhere in
san francisco
it was the most uncanny looking thing i
ever saw and i'm at a loss now to
convince myself that i actually saw it
many of the passengers took up their
morning newspapers today expecting to
see a full description of the peculiar
object that they had seen so plainly and
were surprised and disappointed to find
no report whatsoever
it is the prevalent opinion that someone
in alameda or neighboring counties has
solved the problem of flying in the air
and has been for some weeks putting his
experiment to a practical test